right um yeah if you just checking that
the live stream is working and that song
you can hear me
you
all right good evening members
welcome to the redevelopment committee
25th of June 2020 and welcome to anyone
that is watching the livestream our
agenda item one our apologies for
absence
they've been received from countless
Stanley and number two substitute
members we've had noticed that
councillor Newport is substituting from
countless Stanley councillor hoc way is
not here counselor mrs. Mason would you
like to declare please yes Elsa mr. hook
point was going to attempt to go inside
I don't know what the difficulty is but
I would substitute for him in his
absence him thank you thank you very
much for confirming that item 4 is
minutes of the meeting hound on the 7th
of May 2020 they happy in due course for
me to sign those as a correct and
accurate record of that meeting
agreed thank you no yeah okay plenty of
indication there I think you to receive
declarations of interest
okay just giving a moment as I look
through there are non thank you very
much so that takes us straight on to
item 6 which is the only item that we
have with us tonight which is referred
item from the weekly list land adjacent
to 16 morons morons clothes great
Wakering just to remind members that
there is the report and then there is
the addendum are there any members that
have not seen the addendum that's great
then so it's over to mr. strengths is
going to do the presentation on this one
thank you Thank You chairman morons
close that you'll see marked here with
the little sign is part of a residential
area that's surrounded by farmland on
the eastern side of great white cream
okay just stop you there the sharing
hasn't happened just yet
[Music]
everybody here the motorbike singlet my
Korean is that sharing chairman I think
so yes yes start again
orange chlorines close is a small cold a
residential area that's surrounded by
farmland on the eastern side of great
Wakering over here some 700 and sorry
817 meters or so from the North Sea
coast line across further to the east
with intervening farmland and ministry
of defense land members saw this sites
on the 13th of June the application is
to a site at the western end of Morris
chlorines close if we sit back here to
the location plan and we will see Lucia
here's the pattern of development
chairman new road along the top to the
north
Maureen's Klaus comes in here with
frontage development and there's a
courtyard approach to this area with a
parking area fronting all the buildings
the science is clearly identified here
is red this is an end of terraced unit
with a large Eastside garden the
application before us tonight is to
subdivide that plot as you can see here
with the existing dwelling show and the
curtilage shown us red the cursor the
building you see shown hatched is the
proposed building which is detached from
the terraced block with a meter sideways
shared to give access to both the
remained or to retained existing garden
and the new garden proposed to serve the
dwelling there would be a triangular
paved front garden area that follows the
fence line we saw on the site if we jump
to the next plan the proposal you'll see
is a carrying the design principles of
the existing
building with the brick lower portions
rendered upper warning and tiled roofing
members will have seen if I can try and
zoom on this that the layout at the
ground floor incorporates a carport
feature and the remainder of the ground
floor is given over to a kitchen and
living area with stairs serving and up
stairs the notation of the building is
that it has one large bedroom across the
back and a lounge office or gymnasium
for the remainder of the part with a
bathroom upstairs we look at the context
as we saw this is the northern wall of
the building with the angled garden area
with the future paved area proposed here
behind this fence line showing the
overall design form appearance of the
buildings this is viewed from the
opposite side on some of the mapping
that we have chairman there is
indication of posts indicating this is a
through route but we can see that it is
a brick ball that has been provided
there I don't know how long the clearly
vehicles can't pass through this area
and if members see that there's a number
of reasons the officers found that
attractive reason for refusal on this
application that plan is an opening
chairman but if you if you bear with me
members will have seen from the
recommendation that the site is in flood
zone 3 and I'm rather hoping that this
plan will show the flood zone mapping if
I come out and perhaps to go back in
again that may help let's see what
happens here we go and if if I can get
that to rotate
[Music]
this site this is that the plan needs to
rotate through 90 degrees but if you can
see my screen you see I can't find the
maybe able to get a chance there we go
the site is indicated Laurence Klaus
coming in here we saw on the site visit
that the geography of the layout of the
area is that the application site is
just inside this dark shading overlaying
by the whites hatching which is flood
zone 3 ie and flood zone 3 which is the
area the Environment Agency identifies
as being most susceptible to flooding is
divided actually into two parts flood
zone 3a with the white Chevron's
indicates that there are better defenses
to this part of flood zone 3 than the
balance of the remainder of the zone but
the Environment Agency classifies all
land in England as being in one of three
primary flood zones flood zone 1 is the
area least susceptible for flooding and
where the Environment Agency directs
development should go flood zone 2 is
part partly susceptible to flooding and
flood zones 3 are the most susceptible
to flooding and we saw on the site that
the curtilage of the site that's the
subject of the application falls firmly
within that flood zone so that the
applicant has to first of all passed a
sequential test as to whether this is
the only site available for development
put very simply and then an exception
test that if it can be exceptionally
approved and you'll have seen from the
Office of report that the site is one of
a number of what we would call windfall
type sites where Gardens are subdivided
or small sites of redeveloped which
happen across the district and there
isn't a specified need or shortfall in
the Wakering area that demands that the
site contributes to a sort for a
significant shortfall in the area thus
passing the sequential and then
exception testing so the application is
recommended for refusal
firstly because the flood risk grounds
there is also members will see second
refusal part relating to the inadequacy
of the current flood risk assessment as
identified by the Environment Agency on
on levels the applicant could overcome
that by raising the design of the
proposal slightly but given that it
can't passed in officers view the first
step then this forms a second reason for
refusal now members will have seen from
the side elevation hopefully we have
some photographs here the proposal that
sorry the existing dwelling has a range
of side windows on which it is quite a
bit reliant for the upstairs and also
the kitchen and door to the to the side
of the house we saw her on the earlier
photographs that there's not too much
windows on the front although the front
door is recessed to the side viewing
viewing east widths and then hopefully
we could see that the dominance of these
windows on giving amenity to the house
would be shaded by the dwelling proposed
now the applicant has amended the
application to feature roof lights to
this existing dwelling to try and
improve the light access and has
provided information to do with day
lighting and trading but officers do not
feel that overcomes that the principal
objection that the presence of the
building which is more or less a copy of
the structure of what we see here a
meter from these windows would not cease
to cause a poor internal living
environment for the future occupiers of
the life of this is dwelling the last
reasons chairman concerned car parking
at the site that we are concerned about
is is up here and you'll see from if you
can and from this from this light out
that the applicant proposes one car
parking space in
the shell of the building at
ground-floor but is reliant on a second
car parking space on the outside but
though the application is described as
one bedroom and we've seen from the
layouts that that is the case the floor
space is such that the bedroom could be
subdivided you need a seven and a half
square meter minimum to the state
standards for a single bedroom two
bedrooms are 17 and 15 square meters the
rooms upstairs each so it is possible in
offices use that a second bedroom could
be created and we're alert to that and
the extra car parking space that the
applicant says is possible he's
essentially outside of the ownership of
the site so the applicant could not
control that and you'll see on the
addendum chairman that one of the
residents has explained that when all
people at home as it were this area does
get congested with parked vehicles and
questions that whether if as another
dwelling was added there that access
would be successful the last reason for
on the agenda Chairman is that the
dwelling is within an area that
influences or the recreation margin
occupy could impact upon European
designated coastal sites now that were
the applications of beer pros that would
require a payment of 125 pounds 58 in
mitigation but because the application
is principally being recommended refusal
that payment has not been sought so the
recommendation Chairman is refusal for
the reasons set out the report thank you
members we have a statement from mr.
Brett Telford the applicant that Sonia
is going to read out to us thank you
this application was made as a single
one bed dwelling proposal reference in
the report to to bed is incorrect other
approved schemes have single dwellings
with additional living spaces the red
line great Wakering one bed unit scheme
didn't assume the study could be used as
a bedroom and would not comply with
parking standards under this assumption
when our design change within curtilage
parking the footprint and massing
remained the same to maintain street
scene appearance with the loss of ground
floor area for parking the first law was
yuppies living space our one bed
proposal is compliant with policy high
rates have accepted it to one bed
Wehling and this reason for refusal
should be removed there is a legal right
of way to the new dwellings parking area
so full access from the shared surface
areas is maintained the daylight
sunlight an overshadowing report for the
latest application has been missed essex
policies rely on bre standards in
determining daylight and sunlight few
new schemes fully comply with bre
standards eg Glee clothes infill single
dwelling redline star lay our
application also included plans and
elevations for alterations to the
kitchen with an additional window and
one roof light to each of the West
elevation bedrooms it's improved the
position above the existing levels of
light and removed impact from
overshadowing the dwelling locations at
the same level as the neighboring Glee
property in flood zones 2 and 1 within 5
meters the flood map for planning is
that one in 2500 scale it is more
accurate to review the technical
solutions when the level of discrepancy
at this scale is in meters current
flooding position for this proposal this
location is never flooded even in 1953
there is no current risk based on to
model data to cite Chet showed low risk
from all sources of flooding the EA had
a holding objection to the last two
applications that flood risk in 100
years with climate change would be a
hundred and seventeen millimeters above
ground level based on new model 2 data
the current finished floor is 150
millimeters above ground level
as per typical DPC construction details
ie a 20 millimeter difference from EA
level we can raise levels by 20
millimeters easily and be above the
100-year climate change risk this could
be conditioned in any approval and would
remove the EA holding objection we're in
close proximity to a zone one area so at
no risk with evacuation there would
always be first floor refuge design
resilience is added by first flooring
mains improved site drainage through
both natural permeable landscaping
rainwater harvesting suspended floors
and adjusted garden walls for water
steric storage in flood event approved
flood zone 3 scheme similar to this
include zone 3 336 little Wakering Road
subdivision of housing classification
use C 3 same as morons closed EA removed
objections based on a first full refuge
zone 3 9 Kingston's Farm Road surface
and tidal flooding risk undefended and
intensified land due to size and
drainage sequential test showed land for
housing not identified and no other
developable sites also designated
Greenbelt and coastal protection belt
objection by EA the aécio M South Essex
sfra Rockford noted in zones 3 even
change of you should not be permitted
unless proven to be safe for its
lifetime change of use approved schemes
st. Mary Virgin church change from
church to dwelling pirates and flooding
and only protection measure is first for
all refuge no sequential or exception
test past and scheme not compliant with
being safe for its lifetime waterside
farm zone 3 approval EA advice was
unsafe in future and should pass
sequential in exception test as actual
risk of floods was three point eight one
meters not safe for its lifetime
approved its change of use 286 Wakering
Road approved as demolition and build of
new dwelling brandy whole Yacht Club
highly vulnerable levels elevated above
flood level sequential tests and
exception test not applied as change of
use
our Holiday Park Elbridge in flood zone
won by about 10 meters currently the
climate change impact will mean this
development is not safe for its lifetime
for the sequential test to fail
you need to have similar deliverable
sites in lower risk areas zones 201 our
planning statement and flood risk
assessment addressed the need for
housing in the district based on local
policy and government reports planning
confirmed this self-build plots have not
been delivered and had no information on
similar available sites the allocations
plan includes flood zone allocations
suggesting a principle to accept them if
safe point 19 of the offices report
notes reliability on an appeal case this
appeal has two key considerations of why
it should not be applied technically
different flood risk levels are higher
on the appeal site without change they
reach three metres thus higher risk on
levels and safe egress the EA did not
object on principle it would be safe for
its lifetime with first floor refuge
this appeal decides on land availability
from five years ago and is now outdated
for housing supply as noted in the
points on the government buffer demands
availability of sites has not been
demonstrated and our flood assessment
covers compliance with the sequential
test criteria and to the NPP F this is
flexible living and working dwelling
above national space standards with a
technical solution on low value land in
an existing sustainable community thank
you thank you cancer after year the
member that referred this one do you
wish to speak on it initially I can -
initially the resident of 16 morning's
closed asked me to refer this one in for
the reasons which he's eloquently put
over in his statement about the parking
the overshadowing
the flooding report and the
consideration of overbearing
I put it in for him I think he's done
quite a good report quite a good answer
there and I'd like to hear the offices I
know the officers have answered some
questions but not in detail where he's
put these his actual question is a
statement in that be quite useful please
Thank You councillor mrs. Mason Thank
You mr. chairman I'm note what the
applicants had stated and he's obviously
done some considerable research but any
failure of the past should not be a
reason to repeat that failure now or in
the future whilst the applicant may
intend to use the second upstairs room
other than as a bedroom indeed many
households myself included repurpose a
bedroom for other uses there is nothing
to prevent an occupier using this room
as a bedroom and indeed the layout would
indicate that this would be the more
common use for such a space therefore
the officer consideration of dealing
with this as a two bedroom property is
in my view both understandable and
acceptable having attended the site
visit I consider this application to be
unacceptable for the following reasons
the relationship and impact on the
neighboring property by having an
overbearing impact and by overshadowing
the primary site windows of number 16
would render both the properties
certainly number 16 to dark I would say
and would be unsuitable the report
mentions the garden size spaces that the
SAF says they're under size I know that
the officers consider this acceptable
but we have a policy
with a minimum under garden sighs space
and if the garden space is under sized
there's another reason to refuse this
application with regards to the car
parking I understand that access is
dependent upon land not in the control
of the applicants nor the highway
therefore there is a great risk that the
access would not be available all the
time and therefore would assess abate
any parking problems and we have heard
in the report that there are parking
problems in the area and the carport
itself I don't believe is in keeping
with the neighboring properties the
sequential test and the exception test I
understand from reading the officers
report have not been met but most
concerning is the fact that this
proposal is within plus some risk free
or flood risk so around herbs she which
way around ladies and the objection from
the environmental agency on those lies
indeed with ever-increasing flood risk
generally and most of us have seen
flooding in generally in the area do an
ever increasing flood risk due to
environmental changes not only should
this applicant fail but did you stifle
in my mind that permission would be
given today for the host property number
16 I trust that members will give
appropriate way to the risks involved
and the comprehensive report conducted
by officers and I believe this
application should be refused and I can
with I will move the refusal thank you
thank you can I can I just confirm that
you're moving for refusal on the basis
of the five recommendations printed six
point one point one two they're the ones
in the report back
you'll have to bear with me okay I'll
come back for that clarification later
yeah councillor Reeves plays Thank You
German most of the points I was going to
bring up her being a councillor Kristine
Mason but there is one thing that I
would like to put out that in the
response that the applicant has put
forward he actually mentioned there when
it comes to parking that the additional
parking that he's talking about he has a
legal right of access to legal right of
access doesn't give him a legal right of
parking and the legal right of access
would mean that it would be something
that should be available to other
residents around there so to actually
call that something that is linked very
heavily to this development proposal I
think he's quite wrong the other thing
is that when we went to the site and saw
the conditions that were there to use
the parking space that is actually
proposing is the second parking space it
would be blocking access to the
garden-gate
to number 17 opposite and so for that
reason the inadequacy of the parking
that's the reason being why I would
actually go with refusal application
thank you thank you that's the Wilson
you're indicated Thank You chairman and
the the report that Gore the statement
from the applicant mentioned a couple of
places in whole bridge and the reason
why I bring these up is because these
sites had planning permission long
before the Environment Agency allocated
or categorized land as one two and three
so actually to look at the shangri-la
site which has been brought back into
action this had planned permission for
the 1970s and was used from the 1980s so
I think that with the National the MBP F
we shouldn't really be looking to build
anything in flood zone three and we
shouldn't use these as precedents any
Chairman okay thank you
councillor Newport Thank You chairman
I notice on page six point one nine
forty four that Essex County Council
highways were consulted but there was no
comments received which I do find rather
disappointing as it seems to be a common
trait and I wondered how many times the
officers had actually contacted highways
for a response but generally they're I
think the one of the other points that I
would raise is that the statement from
the applicant contained a lot of
technical detail and I think would have
benefit from drawings etc with that
statement as I did find it hard to
follow in places but I think the reasons
for refusal are compelling and I think
the officers have highlighted them you
know and of the points that they've
raised for refusal I would totally
support and I would second counselor
Christine Mason's proposal to refuse
thank you just for the sake of clarity
as we've got a second to now Casa mrs.
Mason would you just confirm that you're
moving the reasons for refuse on based
on those printed from 6.1.2 the five
reasons Thank You mr. chairman
I am but I'm also including the under
sized garden space as opposed to a
policy SPD to I think it is mr.
strengths I'm sure will correct me if
I'm wrong and the other area that I
think it should be refused on which I
can't see here in those refuses parking
refusal it is in there but the concern
that the is that the land is not under
the control of the applicant and
therefore can't be relied on to
facilitate the building we'll get
clarification on that element in a bit
can I can I confirm then councillor
Newport that that was what you were
seconding yeah I was in councillor
Williams play so we're now moving toward
the the motion for refusal okay Thank
You chairman the points we made I was
about to offer a second floor
councillor mrs. Mason thank you okay
thank you very much
can I ask mr. strengths to come back and
particularly to comment on the two
additional items regard the councillor
Mason is suggesting as reasons for
refused and please Thank You chairman
firstly dealing with the car parking
area and the reason yours feed on the
the agenda speaks to the lack of a space
as it's been said in the debate the
applicant would have right to access
that area despite not withstanding
congestion issues but you can
demonstrate with that reason as
recommended the shortfall it's clear the
size of the building the potential for
subdivision there are previous
applications that proposed a greater
number of bedrooms in the same box or
shell if you like to the building so
officers are confident that that is
demonstrably we have to be careful if we
speculate with some some reasons that
aren't subjective so you know design for
instance is a subjective matter but
where you have perhaps mathematical
standards like for instance the dwelling
of a certain size should have a certain
number of car parking spaces officers
are confident in that in that reason
Ruth's regard to the garden areas you'll
see the officers in this occasion have
not recommended refusal there is a
children's play space area nearby it to
the site it was just through that area
that was bricked off that we saw her
on-site and one of the things we find
when defending these appeals on this
issue
is that the inspectors asked whether the
space was usable and where we stood in
the site visit your recalled that there
was a squarish rectangular space that
future occupiers could make use of it's
not like we sometimes see with some
flatted schemes where the developer has
to squeeze in a lot of car parking
spaces so they say put 10 square meters
over in one corner and 20 in another
part and the totality of the space
provided is broken into small little
compartments because the space offered
on this layout is a usable space and
given the availability of some relief to
that space with the play area officers
didn't feel it would be a reasonable
position to take to refuse permission
for that garden area failing there was a
point raised an earlier chairman if you
wanted me to come back to that about the
applicants statement particularly the
history of some of the sites I can go
through that
I think the applicant statement is the
applicant statement it doesn't form the
formal part of the report so it is it is
what it is so I don't think we'll go
into that in detail I'll come back to
accounts the mrs. Mason you've heard
what the officers have said with regard
to garden space they wouldn't
essentially be comfortable in supporting
that given the proximity of the
playground and I think that proximity is
something that we were all able to see
on the side visit although obviously at
that moment it was closed for obvious
reasons and the the feeling that the the
issue around the car parking is
sufficiently covered so can I ask you to
take your your position on that as a and
if necessary we'll go to we'll vote on
the addition or not of those particular
additional reasons thank you I'm very
happy to defer to the officers expertise
in relation to the car parking issue
having been on the site visit I was just
rather concerned
but it wasn't perhaps covered in the way
that it might have been but I'm sure the
of the officers expertise far exceeds
mine and I'm happy to defer to that I
must admit I am slightly concerned about
the issue of the garden space because I
understand the officer's point of view
but we have policies and I don't see
much point in us having policies if
we're going to always put exceptions to
perhaps a way around this would be and I
gained I would defer to mr. state
strengths on this with his expertise if
we just note that it doesn't meet this
standard garden space thank you I mean
we have other properties less than that
when there has been on other
applications when there has been play
areas nearby so it just strikes me
slightly inconsistent but again I would
prefer to defer to the officer because
I'm not an expert on that okay thank you
so I think we can confidently leave it
to officers to note by whatever
mechanism they have that the garden is a
is undersized but their professional
opinion that the proximity of the public
play space is a mitigating factor on
this occasion so that should anyone try
to quote this as an example for an
undersized garden then the fact that
there is a formal playground within well
10 10 10 metres of the site it is the
mitigating factor wholly on that one so
with that in mind members and just
before we go to the vote as we are doing
this virtually can I confirm that you've
all heard the evidence that you're in
you're an informed position now to make
a judgement amber
on this item can I just have a physical
show of hands that everyone is content
to move on to the vote no one's got any
issues thank you very much the voting we
will do as a Rome color and with this
one I will call out your name the the
format that we've evolved is please say
if you would like there to be a recorded
vote and then your your your vote for
against or abstain did you indicate
something counselor Newport no chairman
sorry okay thank you
right here we go then
councillor ft and no recorded vote and
abstain councillor Eve's no recorded
vote and against counselor mrs. Mason no
recorded vote again okay no recorded
vote against councillor Merrick just
come in then we're saying against we're
actually fighting for a few so yes I
think there's been a bit of confusion
there yeah
for for for clarity members is it's a
fair point that counsel mrs. Mason makes
we we know what we're saying but for
clarity doing well well
I will go and go through this so you are
voting for the reason for the reasons
for refusal as printed or against the
reasons for the approval so if you were
happy with the approval you will be
voting for if you wanted this
development to proceed you would vote
against nova central my boat near
pollution so I start from the top again
so that we've got absolute clarity so
councillor FD only call you fo can
abstain Thank You councillor eaves no
recorded vote for Thank You councillor
mrs. Mason Thank You mr. chairman for
the sake of the confusion they recorded
vote and for refusal absolutely honor no
recorded vote and for councillor Merrick
it's the Newport no recorded vote and
for refusal and mrs. Shaw no recorded
vote and for for for refusal Chancellor
mr. Shaw no recorded vote for refusing
myself against the Smith no recorded
vote and for refusal councillor Western
refusal Shannon cats the Williams T
Chairman no recorded vote and for the
refusal councillor Wilson and you
Chairman no recorded vote and for
refusal Thank You councillor Watson a
recorded vote and for refusal thank you
this give us one moment
I have 12 for the refusal and one
abstention that is a really clear
refusal of that item that is just the
one item that we have tonight so I
believe that at 8:13 I can thank you
very much for your attendance and closed
meeting thank you Thank You mr. chairman
Thank You mr. chairman